consider five powerful performances each
one compelling original unique annex
neurologists turn financial genius a
disloyal and sadistic fur trapper a
persuasive investigative journalist its
Soviet spy pivotal to a prisoner
exchange and an aging fighter named RAC
Rocky Balboa these are the characters
given thoughtful portrayals by the men
nominated for performance by an actor in
a supporting role here are the nominees
Christian Bale
the big short
bridge of spies
Sylvester Stallone
oh sorry and the Oscar goes to mark
Rylance spies
the first Oscar and nomination form are
I've always I've always just adored
stories hearing them seeing them being
in them so for me to have the chance to
work with I think one of the greatest
storytellers of our time Steven
Spielberg has just been such an honor
and unlike some of the leaders were
being presented with these days he leads
with such love that he's surrounded by
masters and every craft on his film
every craft not the least mr. Tom Hanks
people I'm so pleased that our film has
been nominated so many times and as a
face of the film I meet many people in
the streets and it's lovely to have them
they always saying to me would it help
and all that stuff and I think if you
ever wondered about acting with Tom
Hanks would it help the answer is
clearly yes I want to just say thank you
to my fellow nominees I don't know how
they separate my acting from your
glorious acting and these wonderful
films that you're in which everyone must
see I don't know how they separated the
five of us from all the other supporting
actors who are making films at the
moment it's a wonderful time to be an
actor and I'm proud to be part of it
thank you